public sénat et éco des ds vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
m
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle de l'empreinte
écologique du numérique avec cette
question environnement et technologie
sont ils compatibles car la pollution
numérique qui est une réalité même si
elle est invisible c'est ce que nous
expliquera guillaume pitron hauteur de
l'enfer numérique les datacenters sont
excessivement énergivores notamment à
cause de la climatisation nécessaire
pour les refroidir bonne nouvelle
cependant des innovations à l'aise
désormais la facture énergétique vous
verrez et puis sébastien missoffe le
patron de google france sera avec nous
nous dira comment google s'y prend pour
atteindre son objectif zéro carbone en
2030 mais d'abord tout ce qu'il faut
savoir sur l'empreinte écologique de la
tech en une minute c'est parti le
numérique c'est pas bon pour la planète
vraiment
c'est moi de courrier moins de papier
moins de déplacements mais dans le même
temps le digital engendre des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre l'érosion de la
biodiversité ou des déchets
électroniques quel impact sur le climat
au niveau mondial le numérique est
responsable de 4 % des émissions de co2
soit une fois et demi plus que
l'aviation civile et une empreinte qui
pourrait doubler en 2025 et la france
dans tout ça la pollution numérique
représente 2,5 pour cent des émissions
de co2 soit l'équivalent du trafic
aérien au dessus de notre sol et la
circulation de 13 millions de voitures à
qui la faute surtout aux smartphones
ordinateurs télévisions à l'origine de
80% des émissions de co2 les data center
en gendreu 14% des émissions enfin les
réseaux informatiques ne sont
responsables que de 5% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre
et si le plus grand ennemi du climat
n'était pas la voiture ou l'avion mais
l'écran nos écrans bonjour guillaume
bonjour de djoko guillaume pitron
journaliste et auteur de l'enfer
numérique voyage au bout d'un lac aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent alors pc
smartphones tablettes quand on vous lit
on se dit que le numérique c'est le
numérique c'est un enfer pour la planète
pour l'environnement est-ce que vous n'y
allez pas un petit peu fort parce que
finalement le numérique c'est 4 % des
émissions globales de gaz à effet de
serre on pourrait se dire ok c'est
beaucoup mais peut-être intéressons nous
aux 96 % générés par les transports par
le bâtiment par l'industrie non oui mais
si on fait ça on relativise tout et
quand on relativise on y finalement donc
moi le relativisme est un peu un
nihilisme donc je pense qu'il faut
regarder en face chaque poste de
pollution et savoir comment on peut les
améliorer et se pose de pollution là qui
est celui la pollution numérique
s'impose de pollution qui est non
seulement important 4 % des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre c'est quand même
plus que l'ensemble du secteur civil
aérien mondial et puis surtout c'est le
poste de pollution qui croît le plus
vite puisque l'industrie numérique et
celle qui est également croît le plus
vite et à ce rythme là en 2025 on a
doublé cette pollution là donc je crois
que c'est vraiment un des grands
chapitres de la pollution humaine qui
s'ouvre ici avec cette nouvelle
pollution numérique je crois que ça se
fait qu'il faut prendre à bras le corps
maintenant et quand on regarde
l'empreinte en eau en matériaux en
énergie de l'ensemble de l'industrie
numérique mondiale tout ça c'est le trip
d'un pays comme la france et là on se
dit ok mais en même temps c'est pas si
démesuré puissent quand même 5 milliards
de personnes qui sont connectés au web
dans le monde alors en un sens
effectivement c'est vrai je veux dire
après tout on pourrait dire ce n'est que
encore une fois c'est une empreinte
matériel qui est quand même très forte
il suffit de descendre dans une mine
pour se rendre compte qu est ce que
c'est que l'impact écologique du mines
un téléphone portable aujourd'hui c'est
combien de métaux à l'intérieur 50 60 70
78 métaux donc c'est 78 mines
différentes mines pour lesquelles il a
fallu des infrastructures de
l'électricité les métaux il a fallu et
raffiné et des impacts écologiques qui
sont très lourd donc à une empreinte
matériel que vous avez donnée qui réel
et puis après il ya tout ce que ça
génère comme comme revues comme comme
dégâts directs et indirects donc on est
comme dans une technologie qui est dite
immatérielle on parle de cloud en
réalité c'est très matérielles
intéressant c'est que le virtuel en fait
c'est d'abord du matériel et cette
économie dématérialisée elle est tout
sauf immatériel j'espère qu'on nous sui
sax et contre intuitif c'est
complètement contre intuitif parce que
qui est déjà descendu dans la soute du
net je dire quand on envoie un email
lemay qui passe par où ils passent par
des datacenter les centres de stockage
des données il passe peut-être par des
satellites le plus souvent par des
câbles sous-marins mais qui est descendu
dans cette soudaine est composé de tout
c'est de tous et de toutes ces
infrastructures là pas grand monde
finalement donc nous avons une relative
méconnaissance voire totale
méconnaissance de ce qui a derrière nos
vies dématérialisée censément virtuel
est en fait tout cela c'est 1 1 une
occupation de territoires c'est un un
coût matériel c'est un coût en termes
d'émissions de co2 de consommation
d'électricité et finalement toute cette
idée qu'on va dématérialisée nos
existences des matériels et les fiches
de paye mettre nos données dans le nuage
dans un cloud tout ça c'est complètement
faux en fait parce que derrière il ya
une infrastructure il ya tout eu un
couac datacenter d'ailleurs ces
polluants en datacenter salle et ses
odeurs dans un data center c'est un
hangar qui peut faire la taille de cette
pièce dans laquelle nous trouvons il
peut faire aussi la taille de l'immeuble
et dans cet espace là il ya des serveurs
et les saveurs dans lesquels sont
stockés traiter les données et ses
serveurs qui calcule et ses serveurs
selon qu'ils sont plus petit plus un
petit ou grand il y en a aujourd'hui 3
millions sur terre et nous vous moi
david tous les jours sommes perdants
père lance connecter avec son serveur
par jour pour nos actions quotidiennes
et ses serveurs il doit fonctionner en
permanence parce que si jamais il ya une
interruption de service mais en fait y'a
plus internet et ça c'est insupportable
pour le consommateur et donc ses
serveurs tournent en permanence et en
réalité il faut beaucoup d'électricité
pour les faire fonctionner électricité
qu'on produit notamment eu du charbon du
gaz naturel du pétrole les énergies
renouvelables et donc c'est aussi là
qu'il ya un impact écologique si j'ai
envie de lacq et guillaume pitron parce
que j'aime bien son livre
c'est une hypothèse c'est quoi le
parcours mondial encore une fois d'un
like alors vous êtes en face de moi eh
bien d'abord le like il va rejoindre
problement le thème 4g qui se trouve au
dessus de l'immeuble ensuite le signal
va descendre le long des défis l'au delà
de la fibre
en fait ce fil par les parties communes
rejoindre le trottoir sous les saouler
sous les pas des passants il va ensuite
rejoindre un câble en cuivre pour
quelques temps encore puisque orange va
changer comme vous savez ces câbles de
cuivre par des câbles en fibres et puis
il a rejoint d'autres câbles cela il va
ensuite problement traverser l'océan
atlantique par un câble sous marin est
stocké dans plusieurs centres de données
côtes américains parce qu'il a
probablement été émis sur un réseau
social américain il va faire son chemin
inverse dans l'autre sens à 200 mille
kilomètres seconde jusqu'à vous donc en
un rien de temps le lay qui aura
parcouru des milliers de kilomètres donc
guillaume pitron 7 cette pollution
numérique allait elle est réelle mais
elle est belle invisible et c'est ça qui
pose problème en fait en fait ce qui
peut se comprendre qu'on ne la voit pas
et donc on n'est pas capable de dire ah
bah tiens une action numérique elle
pollue rouler en voiture diesel c'est
très concret en termes de pollution et
on le subit immédiatement ce qu'on
respire ce qu'on produit or là on ne le
voit pas on ne le sent pas ce sont des
infrastructures dont j'ai parlé qui sont
souvent stratégique vital en cas de
guerre qu'est ce qui est qu'est-ce qui
sautent le premier sous les coups d'une
requête c'est un datacenter qu'est ce
qui est le premier coupé par un acte
malveillant c'est un câble donc en fait
on regarde ses structures et ses
infrastructures extrêmement discrète les
gars femmes ont pas forcément tous envie
de rappeler qu'ils les évolué d'abord
dans un monde matériel on les voit
partout sur la toile on y voit nulle
part dans le monde physique parce que
rappeler que derrière google facebook
amazon il y à toutes ces infrastructures
polluantes s'est aussi rappelé leur lors
leur contribution ou non aux accords de
paris à la transition écologique est
donc aussi une logique d'un
visibilisation tout ça c'est aussi
organisés du stade manière et donc du
coup on est complètement tenus à l'écart
de cette réalité matérielle là on n'a
pas la perception sensorielle de cette
pollution est le premier des enjeux
c'est nous éduquer cela après le
consommateur ce qui veut l'usagé sega
cette quête de vitesse d'instantanéité
on veut tous avoir en temps réel et la
haute direction pour la planète c'est
pas top en fait nous voulons tout tout
de suite vous savez le drame il est là
quelque part mais complètement moi j'en
suis persuadé vous savez vous êtes un
rond point et puis vous allez avec votre
jeu vous laisser guider par votre google
maps et vous allez sortir à la deuxième
sortie et par la troisième parce qu'il
ya un décalage entre là où vous trouver
là où google maps vous dit que vous vous
trouvez vous allez hurler contre la
machine parce qu'elle a une seconde de
retard ce qu'on appelle la latence et la
danse david jacquot est insupportable
personne ne veut la latence tout veut de
l'immédiateté à la micro seconde près si
possible et tout le monde veut un
internet tout le temps disponible 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et si jamais
il ya un truc son service qu'on a vu
récemment avec facebook six heures
d'interruption de service et
cataclysmique dans le monde de
l'internet et donc pour éviter cela et
bien on multiplie les infrastructures on
les redoute comme on dit volailles sont
pas dans un endroit ils sont donc
peut-être deux trois quatre cinq
peut-être davantage d'endroits sur la
planète de sorte que l'infrastructure
est toujours hyper disponibles et ça ça
a un coût écologique est donc ce qui
coûte écologiquement c'est de vouloir
tout tout le temps de le drian après les
bienfaits de la tête qu'on va pas les
contester évidemment pas seul mais un
thermostat connectés dans une maison ça
permet d'économiser de l'énergie quand
ils voient en somme ça évite pour le
boulot de faire un voyage polluants en
avion ça d'accord là dessus ah mais je
suis totalement d'accord l'internet le
numérique en général permettent d'
immense gain écologique il faut bien le
rappeler ce qu'il y à ce que l'industrie
numérique souvent insiste sur ses gains
là et on oublie de dire qu'on fasse des
gains il ya aussi des coûts est toute la
question c'est celle du sol de
finalement et on dit ça parce que quand
on écoute cercle lobby européen du
numérique il affirme que numérique
entraîné dix à quinze fois plus d'effets
bénéfiques que d'effets néfastes sur
l'environnement est ce que bon c'est un
lobby évidemment mais on sait pas au
final vous avez répondu c'est un lobby
comment est-ce qu'on peut être à la fois
juge et partie de ses propres actions ce
qu'il faudrait c'est nous dit une étude
des ailes à valence est moins dépendante
et donc ce qui est affirmé par ces
lobbys là je suis absolument persuadé
après deux ans d'enquêté aux quatre
coins du monde sur le voyage d'un like
que c'est faux en réalité personne ne
sait et l'honnêteté me conduit à vous
dire que je ne sais pas quel est le sol
entre ce que ça rapporte est ce que ça
coûte avant l'avènement pour la planète
le numérique et je crois qu'il faudrait
avoir tous l'honnêteté de dire que je
retourne ne sais pas parce qu'on n'a pas
assez de recul parce que c'est un sujet
tout nouveau on commence à s'emparer
pour cela il faut je pense commencer à
réfléchir à l'usagé du téléphone
portable c'est ce qui pollue plus la
plus grande pollution du numérique c'est
d'abord les fabrications abl les
interrogations et l'usagé téléphones
portables à les conserver plus longtemps
il faut les conseils depuis longtemps en
fait ils durent environ deux ans en
france à peu près il faudrait qu'il dure
quatre ans moi j'ai acheté un iphone 7
d'occasions donc ils avaient déjà été
utilisés avant ensuite il jules entre
mes mains j'ai repéré j'ai réparé quatre
fois déjà et il peut encore durer deux
ou trois ans et donc et peut-être même
davantage donc y'a vraiment cet enjeu de
garder ces outils le plus longtemps
possible c'est d'abord ça la clé d'un
numérique plus responsable allez merci
merci guillaume pitron donc merci la
ville est journaliste et auteur de
l'enfer numérique voyage au bout d'un
lac aux éditions les liens qui libèrent
alors on l'a vu les datacenters sont
particulièrement énergivores
heureusement des solutions existent pour
réduire leur impact manuel lettre
toutes nos données numériques photos
mails transitent par des câbles sur
terre sous la mer mais aussi dans de
gigantesques datacenter ces hangars hors
norme rempli de serveurs et disques durs
il y en aurait environ 4800 répartis sur
la planète
le souci c'est que ces installations
informatiques fonctionnent 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 et pour éviter la
surchauffe des normes climatiseurs sont
déployés une aberration à l'heure où la
question écologique est au centre des
préoccupations
quel impact sur la planète ces data
center aurons dans les années à venir
comment les rendre plus écologique
aujourd'hui on construit des datacenter
toutes les semaines certains data center
représente une consommation comparable à
la production quasiment d'une d'une
centrale nucléaire toutes les éoliennes
françaises ne suffirait pas à alimenter
les datacenter de france et on projette
de x 4 à peu près cette consommation
d'ici 10 ans 40% de la facture
d'électricité d'un datacenter servirait
à alimenter les serveurs et les 60%
restants à les refroidir avec des
climatiseurs géant
du côté d'annecy à l'abri des regards
une entreprise développe un nouveau
système ingénieux qui rend la
climatisation obsolète en servant sa
chance et aujourd'hui quand on fait un
datacenter qu'est ce qu'on fait enfin
datacenter qui va faire entre 5 et 7
mètres de haut d'accord des faux
plancher on va avoir des faux plafonds
on va voir un système de clip on va
avoir un système de circulation d'air
des ailefroide des et chaude tout ça
pour quoi pour refroidir dans un serveur
un point chaud serge le fondateur de
l'entreprise a décidé de changer de
paradigme en partant d'un constat simple
si j'avais une coupe de champagne dans
mamma prenant petit peu d'imagination et
que ces coupes de champagne je veux la
refroidir qu'est ce que je fais je
refais ronnie champagne où je refroidi
toute la pièce dans lequel est un
champagne
pour freiner le champagne l'image peut
surprendre les composants électroniques
les serveurs et leur connectique
complexes sont plongés dans un bain
d'huile comme dans une sorte de friteuse
sans que le matériel informatique ne
soit altérée l'huile est un liquide non
conducteurs qui absorbent jusqu'à 1500
fois plus de chaleur que l'eire grâce à
un circuit de refroidissement
l'huile est maintenu à 17 degrés un
système qui dans trois ans pourrait
avoir un impact direct sur notre planète
ainsi tous les datacenters et qui on
passerait de 20 % de l'électricité
mondiale à 4 % ce qui veut dire que on
économiserait la bagatelle de 1500
centrales nucléaires à un gigawatt si
pour certains l'enjeu est de refroidir
les serveurs en consommant moins
d'énergie d'autres ont préféré faire de
cette faiblesse une force nous avons
rendez vous chez carnot
initialement ça a été de proposer une
alternative vertueuse au datacenter ces
grandes usines du numérique qui a line
liée d'ordinateurs qui tournent jour et
nuit le concept de carnot a été
justement de vouloir faire quelque chose
de cette chaleur de la valoriser pour
chauffer les bâtiments pour chauffer des
piscines pour chauffer les entrepôts
pour chauffer des sites industriels
arrêtez de refroidir à tout prix les
bâtiments abritant des datacenters et
réutiliser cette chaleur autrement dit
faire du déchet les uns la ressource des
autres
[Musique]
ça roule et c'est dans le garage de
l'entreprise que l'idée a vu le jour une
chaudière en apparence comme les autres
à quelques détails près
ce qu'on trouve à l'intérieur des
chaudières c'est ce que j'ai dans les
mains des processeurs informatiques des
barrettes de ram des cartes
électroniques et c'est de cette chaleur
là la chaleur des processeurs dont on va
se servir pour chauffer de l'eau à plus
de 60° un modèle de chaudières comme
celui ci si on en a deux ou trois on
arrive à produire jusqu'à 50 % de l'eau
chaude nécessaire à une cinquantaine de
logements un système vertueux et
sécurisant pour les clients plutôt que
de concentrer les ordinateurs en un seul
lieu un datacenter carnot les distribuer
les décentralise directement là où la
chaleur va être bénéfique donc notre
approche à nous elle est distribuée les
serveurs ou plutôt les chaudières sont
répartis dans des dizaines de bâtiments
partout dans le monde en cas de panne ou
d' incendies une infime partie des
données seraient touchés aujourd'hui les
idées fleurissent pour lutter contre la
pollution numérique mais l' influence de
la france restent limités la grande
majorité des data center se trouve au
delà de nos frontières
comment google s'y prend-il pour
améliorer son empreinte carbone réponse
avec sébastien missoffe directeur
général de google pour la france bonjour
bonjour des films à très bien merci
alors google vise le zéro carbone d'ici
2030 ça signifie qu'à cette échéance là
vous n'utiliserez plus aucune énergies
fossiles gaz pétrole ou charbon pour
alimenter la fois vos bureaux voler ta
center mais il ya déjà un bout du chemin
qui a été fait j'imagine alors c'est un
gros bout d'ailleurs très importants' de
ré expliquer cela dans le contexte en
effet c'est un engagement qui a commencé
il ya longtemps c'est un engagement qui
a commencé il ya quinze ans qu en 2007
google avait annoncé la carboneutralité
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait compenser
autant de l'énergie carbone ou que nous
compensions c puis la neutralité
maintenant c'est zéro carbone est alors
quelle est la part du chemin qui a été
fait aujourd'hui revenu exactement à
quoi sert cet important en tant
qu'utilisateur qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement ça veut dire qu'en
2030 l'engagement est qu'à chaque fois
que vous faites une recherche sur google
à chaque fois que vous regardez une
vidéo sur youtube à chaque fois que vous
envoyez un email ça va chercher des
informations sur des data center et que
100 % de l'énergie qui viennent
alimenter ses datacenter soit alimenté
avec de l'énergie décarbonée asec là
aujourd'hui on a combien de tirs se sent
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à deux
tiers dans le monde et en europe on a
déjà à 5 datacenter qui soit plus de 90%
et aujourd'hui pas d'électricité à base
de charbon où il y en a encore un petit
peu alors c'est vraiment au cas par cas
j'ai passé éléments de réponse là non
mais au niveau global en effet on est à
deux tirs d'énergie des câbles pour
arriver à ce sens pour cent d'énergie
verte et ce zéro carbone ça sera encore
difficile les deux tiers du chemin qui
reste à parcourir avec de l'innovation
avec
[Musique]
la dernière partie est évidemment la
partie la plus difficile
la première partie et on le voit c'est
facile d'avoir de l'énergie décarbonée
un corps ya du soleil quand il ya du
vent la difficulté est un parti quand il
y en a pas tout le temps et que c'est
difficile de ce qu'est cette information
donc pour y arriver il ya deux grandes
briques la première brique ces
désinvestissements
il n'y a pas suffisamment aujourd'hui
d'énergie décarbonée pour pouvoir venir
se fournir l'énergie à tous et tous ces
data center et donc c'est de continuer à
investir pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur ces 6 milliards d'euros qui ont
été investis qu pour mettre plus de ces
énergies là aujourd'hui sur le marché on
a annoncé l'année dernière pour
l'allemagne que on signe un grand
partenariat avec angie avec cube de
l'énergie éolienne et solaire en plus ce
qui nous permettra d'arriver cette année
en allemagne à 80 % d'énergies
décarbonées dans nos structures might
not le premier enjeu c'est
l'investissement et le deuxième c'est
l'innovation c'est la technologie par la
technologie qu'est ce que c'est c'est de
faire en sorte avec l'intelligence
artificielle qu'on arrive avec des
calculs plus rapide aujourd'hui pour un
même calcul on arrive est cette fois
plus efficace que ce qu'on était il ya
cinq ans on essaye de faire en sorte sur
b
calcul de machine learning qui n'ont pas
besoin d'être fait à une aire spécifique
si vous cherchez un mot si on a besoin
de rajouter des mots spécifiques pour
google traduction on va utiliser le
moment où on est sûr d'avoir de
l'énergie décarbonée en abondance pour
utiliser ce moment là donc choisir les
bons moments de la journée et enfin
énormément d'investissement sur des
batteries pour mieux signaux qu'est
cette énergie la fabrication d'un
serveur ça concentrent 80% de la facture
énergétique d'où la question que vous me
posez c'est est-ce que vous communiquer
sur l'impact carbone de vaud datacenter
sur l'ensemble du cycle de vie et pas
uniquement au moment où vous les
utilisez est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous regardez sur lequel vous
communique alors on peut pourra regarder
j'ai pas les chiffres je ne sais pas
quelle est la source des chiffres que
vous évoquez mais ce que vous évoquez
qui est la question évidemment
fondamental sur ce sujet c'est les
différents visuels on doit s'engager le
niveau ans et au terme de consommation
d'énergie évidemment aussi les 2 et 3
sur lequel on doit s'engager ou un
télescope de lescop trois exactement
savoir encore une fois sur le dos
l'ensemble du cycle de vie l'énergie
qu'on a utilisé pour fabriquer un
datacenter ou pour le détruire derrière
et ce contre oissel usages des clients
et des fournisseurs pardon et précise
sur vous êtes imbattable
sur ces sujets et donc sur ce sujet là
sur ce point sur les autres scoops on
s'engage cette net neutralité c'est à
dire de compenser en termes d'énergie ce
qui a été utilisé pour la fabrication de
ses data center ouais l'impact
environnemental d'un datacenter ça se
résume pas évidemment uniquement sa
facture d'électricité est aussi une
grosse consommation d'eau sound s'est
elle augmente aussi rapidement votre
consommation d'eau et quel impact vous
regarder l'impact s'assure sur les sols
sur la faune sur la flore c'est
lorsqu'on vous regardez sur lequel vous
communiquer aussi l'eau est utilisé
aujourd'hui pour refroidir les data
center sur ça ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est d'abord de voir que
chaque datacenter des réponses un peu
différente ça dépend de nous on est si
on arrive à récolter des eaux de pluie
quel type de on peut utiliser et sur cet
engagement spécifique autour de l'eau
notre engagement est de faire en sorte
qu'on remet 120% de ce qu'on a consommé
c'est à dire plus d'eau dans le système
avec des accords qu'on fait localement
avec des stations d'épuration pour
remettre plus haut dans l'écosystème
alors entre zéro carbone c'est
l'objectif évidemment et donc utiliser
des sources d'électricité
éoliennes ou solaires pour alimenter les
serveurs il faut ce qu'on appelle des
métaux stratégiques
il faut du lithium du cuivre du cobalt
dont l'extraction on sait porte atteinte
à la biodiversité l'environnement vous
assurez vous chez google que tous ces
mets ton était extrait de manière
durable de manière responsable vous
regardez ça aussi oui alors on a un
certain nombre des chartes avec chacun
des fournisseurs avec lequel on
travaille qui est un point important et
puis les engage avec un engagement et il
ya ensuite ce qui est important aussi de
réfléchir la durée de vie
par exemple sur les téléphones mais qui
est un engagement sur lequel on
travaille mais ce qui est très important
c'est de faire en sorte que quand vous
achetez un téléphone on puisse continuer
à mettre les mises à jour des différents
software pendant au moins cinq ans qui
continua à permettre aux utilisateurs on
servait choix à conserver leurs vieux
telle entre guillemets la rejeter
exactement il se trouve que tout est
conservé on le sait dans les datacenter
nos vieux mail datant de 20 ans une
vidéo de chat qu'on a fait qu'on a posté
sur youtube ya dix ans est ce que on
sait que tout ce stockage ça consomme
l'énergie sébastien 2009 pour tout ça
pour une utilité qui est discutable il
ya des bas mais c'est vrai est ce que
rend fou car dessau si longtemps était
consommateur le souhaite mais ce que
c'est vraiment important de conserver sa
aussi longtemps vous ouvrez votre compte
gmail vous pouvez voir combien
d'informations sont stockées et tous ces
éléments là nous aide à faire des choix
rationnels mais toutes
ces chiffres que nous partagions nous
permettent ensuite c'est comme ça quand
déresponsabiliser quelque part les
utilisateurs en montrant voilà voilà
tout ce stockage que ça coûte en
expliciter ses ordres de voir le stocker
les informer et les responsabiliser et
ensuite de l'autre côté en termes de
technologie être capable d'être créative
de continuer à investir ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur la
puissance de calcul qui nous permet de
stocker ces informations avec de moins
en moins d'énergie mais ça fait changer
les comportements c'est suffisant pour
faire évoluer les comportements c'est
pas votre rôle encore une fois l'idée
séduit d'éduquer entre guillemets là à
une forme de sobriété numérique en
matière de pollution ce que c'est qu'il
ya une pollution qui est lié à au
numérique est source de solutions qui
est source de pollution parce que la vie
n'est pas pénible en chinois alors sur
la pollution numérique vraiment pour moi
c'est ses deux jambes sur lequel il faut
marcher la première c'est en effet
montrer les utiliser aux utilisateurs
quel est l'impact c'est un travail
d'éducation qui est vraiment absolument
important et puis la deuxième la
technologie peut aussi aider à cette
sobriété numérique sauf qu'un des
exemples le plus intéressant c'est que
si vous regardez aujourd'hui une vidéo
sur youtube selon vous la regardiez chez
vous sur du wifi ou sur du 4k dans un
métro on va savoir adapter la qualité de
la vidéo en fonction de là où vous êtes
du type d' usage de l'écran que vous
regardez et donc de contribuer à cette
sobriété numérique allez merci beaucoup
sébastien missoffe directeur général de
google france merci merci locaux et pour
réduire la pollution numérique la
solution passe aussi par un changement
de comportement vous allez voir
et oui on peut agir au quotidien pour
réduire son impact bonjour éminent
relatif alors ça peut sembler être une
goutte d'eau dans un océan mais tout ça
mis bout à bout ça peut faire la
différence alors vous l'avez dit cette
pollution numérique elle est invisible
et ça reste assez abstrait pour se
rendre compte sachez qu envoyer un mail
revient à laisser une ampoule allumée
pendant 24 heures à l'échelle d'une
entreprise de 100 salariés sur un an ça
pollue autant que 14 aller retour paris
new york et puis au niveau de la planète
en seulement une heure nous consommons
autant que quinze centrales nucléaires
et la crise sanitaire avec l'essor du
télétravail marié n'arrange évidemment
assez vrai que depuis deux ans on
assiste à une augmentation vertigineuse
de nos mails nous partage de documents
ou encore de nos réunions en
visioconférence la visioconférence qui
d'ailleurs est redoutable il faut savoir
qu'une heure de vidéo qu'on fait mais et
1 kg de dioxyde de carbone selon une
étude de l'université de yale donc un
conseil éteignez vos caméras est passé
en audio si vous le pouvez alors m il
est justement vous avez compiler les
bons gestes pour nous pour nous aider à
nous améliorer et le premier concerne
les recherches sur le web il faut savoir
qu'une recherche sur google ces sept
grammes de co2 dans l'atmosphère quand
on sait que 3,5 milliards de requêtes
sont faites chaque jour vous imaginez
les dégâts alors le mieux finalement
c'est de taper directement l'url dans sa
barre de recherche en tout cas si vous
disposez bien de votre adresse url selon
l'ademe ont divisé par quatre quand même
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
peut paraître fastidieux pour gagner du
temps vous pouvez pourquoi pas
enregistré dans vos favoris les adresses
web vous l'habitude d'aller et puis pour
le reste elle a essayé de limiter vos
recherches au strict nécessaire alors
pour se donner bonne conscience emilie
certains ferment leurs pages web
ouvertes ou régulièrement vident leur
boîte mail ce que sa soeur ou pas
quelque chose alors certains vous diront
que c'est une goutte dans l'océan il
n'empêche c'est fondamental de fermer
les pages dont vous n'avez plus besoin
car même si elles sont inactives les
navigateurs les réactualisée en
permanence ce qui réactive toute la
chaîne des data center pour rien bon
vous n'avez pas répondu sur le ménage de
sa boîte mais là ça vaut le coup alors
alors c'était la même histoire à ses
milliers de vieux mais de vieux spam qui
n'ont absolument aucune utilité pour
vous font tourner donc des serveurs un
peu partout sur la planète donc oui il
faut faire la vie prend l'habitude de
faire le ménage tout comme d'ailleurs se
désabonner des newsletters que vous ne
lisez pas et puisqu'on parle de vos
mails sachets alléger vos échanges il
faut certes quand on envoie une pièce
jointe c'est la cata quand on signe avec
un logo également pensé à envoyer
envoyer vos pdf en basse définition à
utiliser une clé usb ou tout simplement
oui transfert qui ne stocke les données
que sur une donnée une durée limitée
enfin n'oubliez pas que quand vous
cliquez sur répondre à tous et autant de
mails envoyés que le nombre de
dessinateurs et donc autant de serveurs
monopolisé et que mettre quelqu'un en
copie c'est comme envoyer six grammes de
co2 dans l'atmosphère un mot de l'acca
trajet me double à 5 jeux qui sont
également parfois pointé du doigt à tort
ou à raison alors il vaut mieux utiliser
le wifi clairement parce que le wifi
consomme 23 fois moins d'électricité que
la cage et donc quand vous arrivez chez
vous pensez bien à activer le wifi sur
votre smartphone bon dernier mot sur le
streaming vidéo m'a jamais autant
regardé des séries nous toutes et tous
ce grave vous avez gardé la ville le
pire pour la fin le streaming c'est la
plus énergivore de nos activités à
numérique toujours selon l'ademe il est
responsable à lui seul de 1 % des
émissions de co2 dans l'atmosphère pour
se rendre compte regardez à l'est 10
minutes une vidéo en haute définition
sur son smartphone ça revient à utiliser
un four de 2000 watts à pleine puissance
pendant cinq minutes donc l'idée c'est
évidemment pas d'arrêter là si les
séries mais plutôt d'agir aller avec bon
sens on peut par exemple opté pour un
format sd plutôt que hd on peut aussi
désactiver la lecture automatique dans
les paramètres de l'api et puis
évidemment télécharger sa vidéo plutôt
que de la rue en direct ça consommera
nettement moins d'énergie donc à d il ya
des bons gestes à adopter mercy emilie
merci pourvu que ça dure les missions
qui rend les co-responsables c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui magazine à voir ou
revoir sur public sénat il ya du replay
sur lui ça n'a point fr rendez-vous dans
quinze jours
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien décoder ds
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]